great stories were there anybody on the
breakfast club that you really did i
mean you they didn't love working with
or whether it was everybody just great
oh no we all got along it was cool but
what was funny at the time was me and
molly were kids man we were 16 so we had
like homework we had to go back to the
hotel see the skokie hilton or whatever
the it was
and then judd and emilia would go out
and hang out they'd go have beers and
whatever because they were like you know
i don't know 35 when they did the film
no no they were in the early 20s
so molly and i had homework and jutted
out and amelia hung out but we loved
each other man we all got along great i
looked up to all of them to this day i
love do you still talk to them ever i
haven't spoken i ran into judd a couple
years ago he's great he's got a great
sense of humor man that's funny amelo i
haven't seen that much um ali i've seen
over the years the last time we were all
reunited is when mr hughes passed 2010
man we had the oscar thing where they
paid tribute right so i thought that was
very classy of the oscars to do that
because you know they don't often
you know acknowledge comedies as it were
right but molly you still every once in
a while it's been a while since you
talked to her yeah no it's been a couple
years since i've spoken to her but she's
cool very happily married she's got a
bunch of kids she's doing great you know
uh the janitor um oh capitalist
capitalist yeah john capitalist he was i
did the show a couple years back and he
was a guest star and we hit it off yeah
and he came over and karaoke with his
girlfriend oh greg came to the house of
karaoke what a funny guy he is he is so
watch this i produced a film this summer
with a writer director named nick
celotzi and it's not a remake but it's
an updated kind of reimagining of the
breakfast club anyway we got we got
capitalism oh wow so capitals showed up
he's a great guy so uh
and a great comedic actor he's great now
how do you go from john hughes to tim
burton
now tim burton seems like it's got to be
he's i'm sure he's a great guy he is but
it's got to be a different way of
working well at the time when that came
up this is edward scissorhand yeah 1989
man uh so i went to go meet with him
and tim you remember the remember the
cure he looked like a lost member of the
cure right he had the hair and yes yeah
i remember when i went to his office
smith yeah yeah robert smith he had the
leg up in the chair and
he was kind of twirling his hair and
and
really interesting guy very shy actually
i'm very unassuming and very cool
and but he really comes to life when he
directs so
he hired me for scissorhands i
auditioned for him in a room and and
that was a great experience too man um
okay i have a theory about tim burton
i think he is edward scissorhands
here's what i'll explain please do okay
i'll explain
he grew up in in burbank he was a
student of animation his favorite actor
was vincent price right
and
just i i look at him like a modern-day
disney and beyond i mean you look at his
films they're works of art man yeah and
he's one of those you know like
rare
auteurs great directors where he really
has a look and feel of his movies and
they get
more and more brilliant since then right
i mean he went on to do another seven
movies or whatever with johnny depp
right yeah so i just love tim burton man
and i think at the time he felt
i think he probably thought it was kind
of funny because i had sprouted up and
it was a bigger guy yeah you know and
johnny was like you know
uh you know to play that bully i think
he kind of thought it was a fun idea at
the time so great experience we shot in
tampa florida at the time johnny was
with winona and they were in love and
all that